SPEAKER 1: I'm excited to
introduce David Kaplan, who
is the co-author for this
book that Joel Peterson
wrote in conjunction
with David, which
is "The 10 Laws of Trust."
We're going to be
talking more about it.
So David, please introduce Joel.
DAVID KAPLAN: Thank you.
Showing how old I
am, I remember when
I showed up a little while ago.
I had my first full-time
journalism job in this building
back in the age of dinosaurs.
It was a print newspaper.
A lot has changed
since then, including
you guys now being
in the building
and that newspaper not being
in the building anymore.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I met Joel a few
years ago, and have
come to learn in working with
him why he's considered such
a treasure among CEOs,
boards-- he's Chairman
of the Board of JetBlue--
and as a beloved professor
at Stanford, where he's
mentored many entrepreneurs
and students who've gone
on to work at Google,
or who had worked at
Google previously.
For purposes of this book, I
may be his number-one student.
When he told me about
the topic and showed
me some posts he had written
and speeches he had given,
I was skeptical.
Was this stuff about trust pap?
Was he a Pollyanna?
And as I came to learn from him
over many classes and sessions
we would have in person and
on the phone electronically,
and as I helped him form
his thoughts on paper,
which became this book, I
learned that it isn't, and he's
not.
And that's what he's
here to talk about.
Joel?
[APPLAUSE]
JOEL PETERSON: So I think
you're going to interview me.
But before you do, I just
have to tell a Google story.
So I teach at Stanford
Business School,
and the dean there
had Eric Schmidt--
told Eric Schmidt that he
should sit in on my class.
Because as he said it,
the room temperature
is really good in this class.
And whenever I
teach, I spot people
who are not part of
the normal classroom,
and I have them
introduce themselves.
And this was maybe 10
years ago, or whatever.
So I called on this
older gentleman
that was sitting in the class.
I said, would you please
introduce yourself?
And he said, hi,
I'm Eric Schmidt.
Really glad to be here.
And I said, well,
Eric, you need to tell
the class who you work for.
And the class just broke
out into laughter, thinking,
who is this professor who has
no idea who Eric Schmidt is?
Now that was before Eric
Schmidt was Eric Schmidt.
But still, he was a
pretty important guy.
So I do teach, as David
said, a lot of people who've
worked at Google, and then a
lot who come out of the GSP
and come to Google.
So I'm really
delighted to be here,
and I think you're doing
it as kind of a Q&A.
And I don't know where
she's headed either.
SPEAKER 1: You know what?
When I'm given a mic and a free
forum to ask any questions,
I'm excited.
JOEL PETERSON: You're
supposed to be here.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, OK.
We'll switch over.
Already playing musical chairs.
But welcome officially, Joel,
to Talks at Google and so
have you here in New York City.
So before we get right
into the book about trust,
I'm sure you're all
interested in hearing more
about your professional
development and all
the successes you've
had in your career.
So can you tell us a little
bit about your background
and how you got
into the hotseat?
JOEL PETERSON: So I went
to Harvard Business School,
and there was a guy who put a
3" by 5" card on the bulletin
board that said, looking
for a French speaker
to go to the French
Riviera and work.
And I just thought,
my high school buddies
are never going to believe this.
And so I got interested,
ended up taking the job.
I went not to the
French Riviera,
but to Paris, and then to Lyon.
Ended up in the real
estate business.
Long story short, there
was a lot of workouts,
a lot of issues at that time.
I became the treasurer
of the company at I
think about age 29, or
something like that.
And we didn't have any cash.
If you know what a treasurer
does, they manage cash.
We didn't have any.
[LAUGHTER]
And that caused the chief
financial officer to leave,
and I became the chief
financial officer.
So at age 29, I was the
chief financial officer
of the largest private
real estate development
company in the world.
And I didn't have any
idea what I was doing.
And one thing led to
another, and I ultimately
ended up as the CEO of
Trammell Crow Company.
And then I ended up teaching,
starting to teach at Stanford.
And then I started my
own investment firm,
private equity,
growth capital firm.
And then I started a
ventures firm, and then
a couple of real estate
funds, and other things.
So we back maybe now
200 entrepreneurs.
So I started a
number of companies
and backed a lot
of entrepreneurs.
And it's really from that that
these observations about trust
come.
Because I've seen companies
that have failed or not based on
whether or not they build
a high-trust culture.
SPEAKER 1: And so I guess
that's a great segue
into the next question.
So in the book, in a
lot of your writing,
you talk about how your
life is a testament
to the power of trust.
And so in your professional--
in your career,
in your personal
life, how have you
instilled trust in
your relationships?
JOEL PETERSON: So I
started out with parents
who really were trusting.
It was a gift.
I didn't really realize.
But if I would make
a mistake, they
would see that as a preamble
to success the next time.
Have any of you read
Carol Dweck's book?
It's phenomenal, I think.
It's really changed--
I only see a few people
nodding their heads.
But you really ought to read
this book called "Mindset."
And it's fundamentally about
accepting failure, seeing
failure as a
preamble to success.
Well, I started out with
parents that saw that in me.
And then what I try to do is
mimic that in relationships.
And most of the time, it works.
So most of the
time, trust works.
If you extend trust
to people, they
don't like to disappoint you.
They fulfill what they promise.
You have more trust in them.
You trust them with
something greater,
and it becomes this
virtuous cycle.
And so it's really
been repeated.
So I have seven children,
and I always say to people,
I like most of my
kids most of the time.
[LAUGHTER]
And so most of them
don't disappoint me.
Most of them really live up
to-- and if I trust them,
they will actually
try to live up to it.
And so I think that's
actually-- there's
a principle in there for people
who are building businesses,
who are growing businesses.
Pushing the power to people.
SPEAKER 1: And so when
you talk about trust
and personal in your own
house with your family
and then professionally,
how do you define trust?
What does that mean to you?
JOEL PETERSON: So trust is
ceding authority, the ability
to act to another party.
So when you give up
control, you have to trust.
And you're trusting somebody
to look out for you,
to do what's in your interest.
We do it all the time.
We do it with doctors,
dentists, lawyers, accountants.
We do it professionally
all the time.
Sometimes in interpersonal
relationships,
we're a little wary, we're
a little bit cautious.
And rightfully so.
We should be careful.
We should be smart about how
we use this very powerful tool.
I think trust, the
contract that you and I had
if we trust each other,
it's kind of a thermonuclear
contract.
If done well, it's
really powerful.
Take us both to places
we'd not otherwise go.
If poorly done, it
ends in betrayal.
SPEAKER 1: And so that was going
to be my follow-up question.
It's like we rehearsed
this already.
So when you trust somebody
and then they betray you,
how do you overcome that?
And how do you re-empower
yourself to trust them again,
or how do you kind of cope
with that type of situation?
JOEL PETERSON: So it depends
on the level of betrayal.
You know, if somebody says
they're going to do something
and they don't do it, that
is, in a sense, a betrayal.
But that happens all the time.
And sometimes, it's for good
reasons that they don't do it.
And so if it's a
minor betrayal, I
try to get to the bottom
of it and understand it.
Because you want to stop those
sorts of things early on.
Otherwise, they metastasize.
And you end up not
trusting somebody,
and it builds, and
you start looking
for data that proved that
you shouldn't trust them.
And then trust ends up going
in the wrong direction.
So I think it's important to
trust in little increments,
and then measure it, see how
it's going, and then give more.
Now when the betrayal is
larger, when it's really
a betrayal of sort
of a character
where people have really
violated something deep--
my guess is every one of
you have trusted something
in your life, and every one
of you has felt betrayed,
you know?
And it's a tough
thing to overcome.
So I would say that if
it's one of those betrayals
of character, the
odds are you're
going to wake up in the
middle of the night,
thinking about it.
It's going to be the
first thing on your mind
when you get up in the
morning, and you're
going to feel bitter about it.
My advice is get over
it as fast as you can.
That may be years, really,
before you get over it.
But the way you'll know
that you've gotten over it
is you're starting to
think about the future.
You're not thinking
about the past.
You're not looking in the
rear view mirror and saying,
I can't believe this
person did that to me.
So I think you want to get to
the future as fast as you can.
SPEAKER 1: And so
it's interesting,
as we're talking about
betrayal and trust
and with elections and all
the political climate that's
currently happening right now,
there's a lot of constant--
you know, there's a lot
of disrespect, I think,
around the political community
right now of the bashing
and talking down
upon each other.
What are your views on
the political climate?
And what advice would you
have for the candidates?
JOEL PETERSON: It's toxic.
And what happens is when you
get into polemics and people
get far out on the edge, it's
very tough to knit things back.
You know when you
have strained trust?
It's very tough.
So if people are thinking about
actually leading an enterprise
after there's been that kind
of a battle, it's really tough.
And so I was just reading
"The New York Times"
that 2/3 of the electorate
trust neither of the leading
candidates.
That's shocking.
For 2/3 of Americans not to
trust either of the leading
candidates?
I mean, I find that
just appalling.
Well, what that
means is you can see
that it's going to be very
tough to bring people together
after that.
So I don't feel great about it.
SPEAKER 1: And is there
advice that you have?
Can they overcome that
reputation that they have?
Say, if they do win
the seat, knowing
that 2/3 don't trust them,
how do they overcome that?
JOEL PETERSON: So trust
is one of these things
that you build up a
molecule at a time.
You build trust a conversation
at a time in your life.
And you can destroy
it in a single act.
So I actually think that this
process of bashing is damaging.
I also think that the American
people are the clientele.
And so we're the ones who are
selecting the people that we're
going to hire.
Fundamentally,
we're hiring people
to be the president
of the United States.
So it says a lot about us.
And I would say that everybody
in here's a millennial,
it looks like to
me, pretty much.
It's one of the great things
about-- well, maybe not.
[LAUGHTER]
Not David for sure.
Not me for sure.
But this is a company
of millennials.
And you know, if you look at
the millennials, they really--
so I get asked
this all the time.
They're hardworking,
they're smart,
they want to do the right
thing, they care about meaning,
they care about
balance in their lives.
But fundamentally,
I think they've
become a bit of a
mistrustful generation.
And if you look at the reasons,
I mean, they were told,
buy a house.
That's the right thing to do.
And then they've seen their
neighbors be foreclosed on.
They've said, get married.
And they see their families--
divorce in their own families
or neighbors.
They were told, go to college.
You know, get a college degree.
And they find that people
get college degrees
and they end up with a mountain
of debt they can't repay.
And so on and on.
A lot of these things
they've been told to trust,
trust this stuff.
Go to work for a
company, and then they
find that people get laid off.
So they've learned to be a
bit mistrustful, a bit wary.
And there are good
reasons for that.
So in some ways, we have an
electorate that's mistrustful,
that's a bit angry.
And so the candidates
speak to that.
Candidates really are just
reflections of what's going on.
And so I think when you have
that in the candidates--
so I don't blame the
candidates altogether.
I kind of say, this is
where we are right now.
And I think it
really takes somebody
to put their arms around us
and say, hey, what do we share?
There's a lot more that
we share than divides us.
SPEAKER 1: So as you're
describing millennials--
and I think I'm probably one
of the older millennials--
but that really
resonated with me.
I think a lot of how I
think and approach things
is very similar to what
you said with the weariness
and the mistrust of
a lot of decisions
we need to make in life.
In your book, you talk about
different communication styles
of how you can learn to
trust or kind of clearly
communicate trust to others.
Can you talk a little bit
about the communication styles
and the methods?
JOEL PETERSON: The most powerful
way to develop trust is to act.
Whatever you do, if your words
and your actions sync up,
people tend to trust you.
People are super smart.
So I've found that even
the newest receptionist
in the company knew all kinds
of stuff and picked up on stuff,
whether people were
trustworthy or not.
So the first thing
is that you've got
to sync up words and actions.
If they're out of sync, it's
very hard to develop trust.
The second communication thing
that I always tell to people
is, part of communication
is listening.
If I explain the most important
part of communication,
if you've been around
a good listener,
they tend to capture
what it is you're saying.
And they tend to
listen until you've
been able to
explicate or tell what
it is you're talking about.
They've captured it in a way
that they can reflect it.
And if somebody can communicate
in that way as a good listener,
they've done a whole lot.
And then I think the
other thing I'd say
is that in a
corporation, in a family,
in any kind of an organization,
is communicate lavishly.
What that means is you
don't withhold the bad news.
You know, I see a
lot of people who
try to manage-- [INAUDIBLE]
talking in the news business,
you guys know that people
hold the bad news till Friday
afternoon, and then dump it.
All those kind of manipulations
people think work--
AUDIENCE: But we in
the news business
try to publish it
Friday morning.
[LAUGHTER]
JOEL PETERSON: Even
if it's not true?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOEL PETERSON: Yeah.
[LAUGH]
But I think this
idea of disclosure,
of telling people bad
news as well as good news.
Because people are smart.
People know.
If you learn all of the
important news at the water
cooler or in the
newspaper, you've
actually damaged the trust
within the organization.
So I think you have to
communicate bad news.
You have to communicate before,
during, and after events.
And a lot of times, people
think that if they just do one,
or they can have a news
flash, and that's it.
My experience is most
events have a long lead-up.
They have kind of a crescendo
that something happens.
And then there's
a period of time
when there's kind
of a denouement.
And I think really
effective communicators
realize that people need to know
information all along the way.
So I think those are three ways
to think about communication.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks
for sharing that.
And so given that
you need to be more
transparent in
your communication
and kind of message at
all points of the process,
how have you incorporated that
in the business environment
as a leader yourself?
And then I guess, what advice
do you have for us as Googlers
to instill that type
of leadership quality
in our future as we
continue to grow?
JOEL PETERSON: So I've tried
to think about it two ways.
One is sort of
broadly leading a team
or whatever where you have
to communicate objectives.
When I was a managing partner
at Trammell Crow Company,
for example, I used to write
a partner's letter every two
weeks, and I would make sure
that everybody heard from me,
and [INAUDIBLE].
And JetBlue, every Monday
we send out a letter,
and it's from a member
of the management team,
to all 19,000 employees.
So there's that kind
of communication
that keeps everybody on
top of whatever's going on.
The other kind, though, is
I think a much more personal
kind, which I think you can do
even if your enterprise doesn't
do it.
And to me, it's this notion
of a standing meeting.
So wherever I am, I tend
to go around and stop
in people's offices and just
say, how are things going?
What are you working on now?
What obstacles are you having?
Is there anything
I can do to help?
And then typically, it's nice
to ask them about their lives,
about their family, and to
remember something about what
was going on in their lives.
I mean, caring about
people is actually
a really powerful thing.
And a lot of people don't do it,
or they think it's a technique.
You actually have to care.
It really has to matter to you.
If you do that,
that communicates
all kinds of things.
If you don't, then people
see through it again.
SPEAKER 1: And is that the
tool or the secret tool
that you use to empower your
employees within the companies
that you lead?
JOEL PETERSON: I
don't think there's
anything secret about it.
I think-- I mean, it is
out of these conversations
that you end up figuring out
who to empower and how much.
My view of empowering people is,
ultimately what you want to do
is empower people who are
closest to the customer.
So it's wherever the action
is, you want people to feel
empowered to make decisions.
You get better decisions
if you can do that.
But you can't do
it all of a sudden.
You can't just dump all the
decisions of the organization
on your youngest,
most remote people.
So you have to do
it incrementally.
And then you measure.
So one of the
chapters in the book
is about the power
of accountability,
why there has to
be accountability.
If you're going to trust people,
they have to be accountable.
And so they need to know
what you're measuring.
Otherwise, it's not real trust.
You can surprise
them by, saying, oh,
that's not what
we were measuring.
So I think you kind of move
to something like that.
SPEAKER 1: So I was just
referencing my notes really
quickly, because one of the
things that when trust comes up
and when you talk about
the 10 laws of trust,
you immediately think of some
of the synonyms or close words
which is trust,
respect, honesty.
How would you kind of
combine them together,
or how do you see them all
in relation to one another
in how you can live your
life in a powerful way
and in an honest way?
JOEL PETERSON: Well,
so I think you've
mentioned about your virtues
that we all aspire to,
and we all like in
our friends or spouses
or significant others.
Those seem [INAUDIBLE].
I would say, though, that
I categorize all of those
under the rubric of character.
But that's only one
element of trust.
If somebody has
high character, that
is not enough to trust them.
We think that this warm,
fuzzy feeling-- ooh, gosh.
I really like her.
Therefore, I trust her.
But I was ask my
executives that come in
to take these exec
courses at Stanford.
Well, would you trust your mom,
whom you trust, high character,
to fly a 747 to London?
And they say, well, heck no.
Well, why wouldn't you?
Well, because she doesn't
know what she's doing.
She's not competent.
She's not competent to do that.
So if you want to
trust somebody,
it doesn't just
start with honestly.
That's the feel-good
care element.
There's an element
of competence.
If you're going
to trust somebody,
they have to be competent.
And if you expect
to be trusted, you
have to be competent, which
means you deliver on what
you say you're going to do.
And then the final
thing I tell people
is, people that you trust have
to have the authority to act.
There's no point in
telling David here
who's a lawyer that
I'd really like
not to pay taxes this year.
And you're a lawyer.
David has high character.
He's very competent.
So I'd just like
not to pay taxes.
He doesn't have the
authority to do that.
He can't make that happen.
So for me to trust him to keep
me from paying taxes is folly.
It's not smart trust.
So trust is, I think, a
really hard-edged principle.
And you can get
really good at being
thoughtful about who you trust
by being kind of analytical,
by factor analyzing.
What is it that you're
really trusting?
And so it is those things
that you mentioned,
but it's not enough.
It's inadequate.
SPEAKER 1: Well, thanks
for pointing that out.
And in Joel's book,
he does define--
you define the character and the
competence and accountability
pretty well and pretty
detailed as great tools for us
to leverage, I think,
in our day-to-day.
And I want to give you
guys an opportunity to ask
him some questions as well.
So we're going to open
the floor to questions.
So there's a mic.
Adeola, if you don't mind.
Adeola right here is going
to run around with the mic,
and just raise your hand
if you have a question.
She can come up to you.
JOEL PETERSON: Sorry.
I didn't mean to
ignore you over there.
AUDIENCE: No worries.
I'm not a millennial.
[LAUGHTER]
JOEL PETERSON: So sorry.
AUDIENCE: Do you think
trust can be taught
and/or learned if you are
working with someone who you
do not believe exhibits trust?
Is that something that you
think a person can develop?
JOEL PETERSON: I
think they can, but I
think they have to think about
all three of those areas,
getting good at all
three of those areas.
I think most things
can be learned.
I teach a leadership
class as well at Stanford.
And a lot of people used
to think, well, leaders
are to the manner born.
In other words, they come
up with a certain DNA,
a certain whatever, birthright
that makes them leaders.
And that may have been
true a century or two ago.
It is no longer true.
You see leaders coming out of
all kinds of walks of life.
And those who become
intentional and say,
these are the
things about leaders
that make them powerful as
leaders, people who understood
you can actually develop that.
I think it's the same
thing with trust.
So I actually think that if
somebody were to take seriously
these 10 laws of
trust and say, I'm
going to operate within
these guardrails,
these are the
guardrails that really
are going to set my
behavior or organization,
they will get better.
They'll become more trustworthy.
They'll become more able
to communicate effectively,
to empower others.
And all of these things
tend to self-reinforce.
And so, yes.
Long way of saying yes.
I absolutely think people can
learn to be more trustworthy.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Steven.
I am a millennial.
OK, a little different.
I'm very interested
in the fact that you
serve on JetBlue's
board, and I'm
super interested in aviation.
One of the events, talking about
communicating during events,
was when the flight attendant
went off the slide at JFK.
JOEL PETERSON: Thanks
for reminding me.
AUDIENCE: Right?
Well, I'm sure as
a board member,
you probably had to
deal with some of that.
But what was interesting
is it kind of broke--
and probably why the
story was so interesting
was it broke people's trust.
It broke JetBlue's
trust in that person
and fulfilling their duties.
And someone as a
passenger saying,
I trusted that person
to be there for me
and not to be jumping
off the plane.
How did you communicate
through that,
and how did you figure
out-- is this just one
person, organization that's
operating on the outside,
or is there a broader
issue within the company
that you had to address?
JOEL PETERSON: That's
a great question.
That's one of the things you
ask when something happens.
We've had several of those
incidents over the years.
And so you always
ask that question.
What we did in that
particular incidence was
we asked all the
employees to say,
what do you think we should do?
How should we handle this?
Because it was their peers.
It's their company.
They own it too.
And they want to have-- they
want to live the values.
And they were basically
the ones that said,
this person needs
to be moved out.
I think if management had just
come in and say, OK, can this,
you would have a lot of people
kind of coming to their rescue,
and whatever.
Whereas because
they were empowered,
they all sort of
came together to say,
you know, this is the
right thing to do.
I think one of the toughest
issues for any company--
if you're going to build
a high-trust organization,
a whole lot of
what you have to do
is get the right
people on the bus
and get the wrong
people off the bus.
And so I would say
with 19,000 employees,
we've got some of the
wrong people on the bus.
And that takes courage to go
in and get them off the bus.
Now you can do it generously,
graciously, or whatever.
But it's a constant
management challenge.
So I will say one
other thing that you
might find interesting,
and maybe you've
done that here, too.
But we have five values.
Values are just priorities.
And can you guess what the most
important value is a JetBlue?
AUDIENCE: Safety.
JOEL PETERSON: Safety.
Exactly.
We fly 35 million people
around every year,
and nothing is more
important than their safety.
That's the number one value.
Which means if it's your value,
if it's really your value,
you have to spend time on it.
You have to spend money on it.
People who give lip
service to values and then
don't spend time or money
or mental energy on it,
they're fooling you.
You can't trust them.
So if you're going to
say, these are our values,
you have to live
true to those values.
And the second one
is caring, you know?
And I don't know if any of
you saw-- there a YouTube
video that went viral.
There were stories
about what went on
in Orlando after that shooting.
I mean, we were getting
ready for a JetBlue offsite
in Washington, DC.
And so our CEO was up to
his eyeballs in issues.
As soon as that happened,
he got on an airplane
and flew to Orlando, even
though everybody was flying in.
Nobody knows that.
The press didn't
pick up on that.
The press picked up
on flight attendants
who were empowered to
do the right thing.
But it got started because
the CEO really cares.
So we had 40 people
at JetBlue who
were impacted at some level
or another in that thing.
And having the CEO fly down
there and be with those people
said that value
of caring matters.
And so you go down
all the values,
and you really check
yourself against.
If these are our values,
do we spend time, money,
and mental energy
on those values?
If not, they're not
really our values.
You know, all of us
would like to say, ooh,
these are the ones.
I'd love for these words
to be associated with me.
But I will tell you, if you're
not spending your time, money,
or mental energy on it,
they're not really your values.
Your values may be watching
soap operas or sports on TV.
You know?
I have some values
that I'm not proud of.
But I have to say, if it's
what I'm spending my time on,
they really are my values.
So I think you're going
to have some of that,
but I think you always have
to true up to your values.
If you're going to build
a high-trust organization,
you hold yourself
accountable to those values.
Was that at all Responsive
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JOEL PETERSON: Yeah.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: For the relations
that have actually
gone really sour-- for
example, at the workplace
or in personal
space, sometimes I've
seen most people
or organizations,
they kind of cut ties
and say, hey, this
has already gone sour.
Why invest too much time
in building trust here?
It's already gone.
Do you have, like,
something different
for in some situations?
Or generally, I've
seen, like, all right.
There's no trust, so let's
get rid of these employees,
lay off, in case of
families or a divorce
or siblings don't
talk to each other,
parents don't talk to
their kids for a long time.
The kid has married out
someone else they didn't like,
or something like that, right?
So in those situations
I've seen mostly
that they just cut one dimension
and then live their life.
And I've seen people
just die [INAUDIBLE].
They just live their
life, and then die, right?
So what happened?
Like, would they be better
off working on the trust
there before dying?
Like, you're all
going to die anyways.
But should be working
on that [INAUDIBLE],
and is there something different
to do than generally what
you suggest?
JOEL PETERSON: So I don't
think you want to die bitter.
I don't think you
probably want to die.
But don't die bitter,
for one thing.
I think there are a number
of betrayals that are really
very difficult to repair.
And I think you're
better off in those cases
moving on to something
where you can
build high-trust relationships.
It takes too much energy.
So that's one of the reasons
I say, catch it early.
If you find that
something has happened,
get it early,
because it will just
arise later in an uglier form.
So catch it and
nip it in the bud.
Now I would say that if
the stakes are really high,
like a family member, a
spouse, if there are children
or whatever, you may
say, it is really worth
paying a big price.
Usually to repair trust,
though, it takes both parties.
And I find it's
very difficult to do
if the party who's offended,
the other doesn't say, I'm sorry
and ask for forgiveness
and really mean it.
And forgiveness is only when
the offended party forgives.
It's not when you
say, hey, I asked.
You know, a lot of people
think, well, you know,
I'm sorry if you felt that way.
That's just a blame.
That's not an apology.
So I think it really
requires a sincere apology,
and then the stakes
have to be high enough.
And then I think you have
to let go of the blame.
I remember one time having
a really tough time.
David knows this
because we had it
in the early version of the
book and decided to take it out.
Because I was really
struggling with a betrayal.
I mean, it was really
eating me up for too long.
And I had a friend who gave me
"The Count Of Monte Cristo."
Many of you ever read that?
It is a delicious
version of getting even.
It is just unbelievable.
But in the end, Edmond Dantes,
who's the offended party,
decides he's better
off moving on.
He's actually becoming
the person that he hated.
So it will canker your soul.
It will eat you up.
So it's in your interests
to let go of it.
So if it's high stakes, I would
say get in and work at it.
Catch it early.
Get in and work
it out if you can.
If you can't, move
on to something else
where you can
actually build trust.
Life's too short to
live in these situations
behind betrayal.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
about the other person?
JOEL PETERSON: They always do.
They always do.
Nobody ever did something bad
without having a justification.
So it starts out with people
thinking that they were right.
And so I think you have to
start out understanding.
And so the times that
I've worked with her
have not been the
most serious ones.
But ones that are a degree
below that, I asked people
to tell me what went on,
what we were thinking,
how did this develop?
And usually they
have a narrative.
Sometimes it's baloney,
but sometimes there's
really something to it.
I think one of the more powerful
things that's happened to me
is when I've said, what did I do
to contribute to this problem?
That's a really good mindset.
It's a hard mindset to have.
But you almost [INAUDIBLE],
if you're really honest,
what did I do to
contribute to this?
Odds are pretty good that
you contributed something.
You had a question.
By the way, while the mic's
coming to him, let me say,
I was speaking-- do any of
you know what Bonobos says?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOEL PETERSON: Good.
Hooray.
I was the original
investor in Bonobos.
I was the first investor, and
I'm on the board at Bonobos.
And they had me speak
to a company thing.
And I said, you know, any
time I go into a situation,
I think about, what
would winning look like?
And just try to imagine what
winning would look that.
And the group was really
quiet and everything.
And I said, you
know, to me, winning
is having all of you
asking lots of questions.
And so I feel like
I'm losing right now.
And so the hands
were up all over.
[LAUGH]
So I'm feeling like
I'm not winning big
here yet, so I'm encouraging.
SPEAKER 1: Maybe
you've already answered
some of their questions.
JOEL PETERSON: Maybe so.
Yeah.
Maybe so.
AUDIENCE: So I love the
notion that if you put trust
in somebody, most of the
time, it's reciprocated.
And I've kind of experienced
that in my own life.
But I was wondering,
is it actually
possible to protect
yourself from sort
of trusting in somebody that
you could not have trusted?
Like, I [INAUDIBLE] conservative
by only waiting until somebody
trusts you to trust them back.
Or do you feel like trusting
in everybody is worth it?
Because one of the
couple of times
that you might have
your trust broken
is a very small loss compared
to all the relationships
that you've built.
JOEL PETERSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
So my view is, it's
good to be the leader
and to trust somebody.
You don't need to wait
for them to trust you.
Trust people.
But do it in increments.
Do it in small amounts.
I tell a story in
the book about my dad
trusting me to learn how to
drive up and down our driveway.
And we had a 100-foot
long driveway,
and it had an L-shaped drive,
and you'd back the car out
of the garage, hit the
curb, and then drive
up and down the driveway.
And so I backed the car out
of the garage, hit the curb,
and then accelerated.
And I forgot to
put it into drive.
And I went up over the curb
and down onto this berm,
and hung the car up.
And I tried for a
while to get it up,
and I realized I couldn't.
So I went in to get my dad.
He got the neighbors out.
They pushed the
car back up there.
And I thought, well,
that's it for driving.
I probably won't drive ever
again, but certainly not
that car.
And as he was walking back
into the house, he turned to me
and said-- tossed me
the keys and said, son,
don't forget to put
it in drive next time.
That image has really
been a powerful one to me.
Trust people a little bit.
If they screw up a
little bit-- and it
wasn't for lack of effort.
It wasn't for
reasons of character.
It was just, they screwed up.
Toss them the keys
again, talk about it,
say what you need to do,
and then try it again.
So I think you initiate
trust, but you do it
in small enough increments
that it doesn't kill you
if they betray it.
Because I think if you trust
100 times, one or two times,
people are going to betray it.
So you just have to
know that with trust
comes the risk of betrayal.
SPEAKER 1: And so is there a
way for you to measure trust?
Like, is there some
type of formula,
or is it just
judgment that you use
to understand how trustworthy a
person is, or how much of that
trust you want to instill
in that relationship?
JOEL PETERSON: Yeah.
So I do a lot of
hiring of people,
and I do deep reference checks,
and I do second or third-order
reference checks.
Because I think you can
learn a lot from that.
I also go deep into somebody's
background, all the way back
to maybe grade school.
And I try to understand,
what were the inflections?
When they decided to go left
rather than right, what was it?
And I have found a
couple of things.
One is that when people tend
to move away from things,
they tend to be less
trustworthy than people
who are moving toward things.
So people who are always
seeing the next interesting
opportunity tend to
be more trustworthy.
I've also found
that people who tend
to be winners and who
tend to win on teams--
there's something about teams.
And that's not say I don't hire
people who don't work on teams.
But there's something about
working on a team where
you have to rely on each other.
You know what I
find a lot of times
with the straight-A students,
which are probably everybody
in this room here-- good.
We've got one like me.
[LAUGH]
But they did all the work.
You know, you could be
given a group project,
and they would do the
whole group project,
because they couldn't
trust anybody else to do it
as well as they did.
Well, people who have
learned to live on teams,
if you play on a
football team, you're
not able to drop back,
block the people who
are trying to tackle you, throw
the pass, run down the field
and catch the pass.
So you have to have teammates.
So I tend to find
that that's one thing.
And then I do a
little bit at a time.
And then I just make darn
sure that I'm trustworthy.
So if somebody tells me
something that's confidential,
I will never breach that trust.
You have to have really strict
rules on things like that.
There's no such thing as, you
know, let me just tell you.
I shouldn't be telling
you this, but-- you know,
that's a trust breaker.
SPEAKER 1: So when
you look at red flags
when you're going
through that, so one
of the things you've said in
the fluctuation and the way
they direct the conversation
of going away from something
instead of moving forward,
are there other red flags
that you could kind of
give us as best practices
to see as, like,
a sign of distrust
or a sign of warning
or a caution sign?
JOEL PETERSON: Yeah, I think
another one that I always
pick up on is how transparent
and open and vulnerable people
are.
High-trust people
tend to be open.
They tend to be transparent.
They tend to say, ooh, I
hadn't thought of that.
Low-trust people tend to have
an answer for everything.
They tend to hold their
cards close to the vest.
They tend to spin you on stuff.
They're know-it-alls.
So there's a lot of tells.
There's a lot of ways to pick
up on somebody that you really
wouldn't want to be in
the foxhole with them.
So I think our instinct,
I think our heart
tells us a lot of things that
our mind doesn't tell us.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
And as Joel mentioned,
I am not a millennial,
which means I've worked
for many different managers
and bosses, some who
were Machiavellian,
some who were micromanaging.
And I am just
wondering, how do you
deal with an untrusting
manager or boss?
JOEL PETERSON: So there
are two things you can do.
One is you can get
feedback to them.
You may be able
to do it directly,
or you may have to sort
of initiate a 360 review.
I did that with a number
of folks who I just said,
it would be good
to do this to get
the message through to them.
And the other thing you
can do is change jobs.
It's very difficult to get
people to change their value.
You know, if you have a
values conflict with people--
so I have this
hierarchy of alignment
that I look at where
fundamentally, the alignment
starts with values, which is the
most profoundly felt thing that
doesn't change very often.
It moves then to your
objectives in life.
From your objectives, you have a
strategy to get something done.
From strategy, you have tactics.
Who's going to do what, by when?
And then from
there, you get what
you measure in your controls.
So most of the ones
below objectives
can easily be compromised.
It's the one where you get
all the way up to values
where my view is, people don't
very often change their values.
So if you find you have a values
conflict, you're not trapped.
Most millennials, to get
back to the millennials,
most millennials believe
today that they'll have
11 jobs during their work life.
And I think that's wise.
I mean, I'm actually going
to write an article in praise
of millennials, because they
figure a lot of stuff out that
my generation didn't.
So they've figured out, well, if
there's a conflict over values,
I move on.
I do something else.
So I think you have
those two options.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Adeola.
AUDIENCE: It sounds like you've
had incredible experiences
throughout your career.
I'd love to hear an
anecdote about a situation
where you had to build trust
to achieve a business outcome,
and what you did to do it.
JOEL PETERSON: So I
think one of the times
that trust matters the most
is under stress, under duress.
So I was involved
in a turnaround.
Fundamentally, what
a turnaround means
is that you're out of money.
You can't pay suppliers.
You can't meet payroll.
You can't-- I mean, you're
basically in extremis.
And so the only thing that's
going to get you through that
is if you have trust, if
people believe you're going
to do the best job you can.
You know, the
lenders will take--
so I was in the real
estate business.
Lenders will take
back property if they
don't feel like you're honest.
But otherwise, if
they feel like you're
honest and trustworthy and doing
the best job you can, why would
they want to take that on
and find somebody else?
So for me, it was a question of
calling individually on lenders
and just giving my-- and
it's not saying, trust me,
I'll do a good job.
It was saying, here's
why you should trust me.
Here's my plan.
I think plans and
specifics actually
allow us to then trust.
It's not just the warm,
fuzzy, trust me thing.
So for me, in a workout, it's
really made all the difference.
Is that responsive?
Not so much.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE].
JOEL PETERSON: You wanted to--
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
Just from what you
were talking about,
it sounded like how
you build relationships
with people and so
on and so forth,
like, I think personally,
I've felt like in my career,
like, building
those relationships
and going the extra mile
does make a huge impact,
but I don't have as
interesting experiences being
the chairman of a board
of a major airline
or working with the biggest
global real estate developer,
and things like that.
So I figured you might have
more interesting situations
that you could talk about.
JOEL PETERSON: So I wasn't
always the chairman--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
--does that mean we're done?
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Sorry.
JOEL PETERSON: So I recall
a time early on in my career
where I totally screwed up.
I was dealing with a
financier here in New York.
And I just botched
the negotiation.
And we used to talk on
Saturdays and do a deal,
and then we'd make the deal, and
he'd wire the money on Monday,
papers to follow.
It was a high-trust
relationship.
And so I screwed this thing up.
And I remember him calling
me first thing Monday morning
and saying, I don't
think you really meant
to set this deal up this way.
And I thought, oh my gosh.
He is right.
I totally screwed that up.
Well, what do you think my
trust relationship with him--
we had dinner just the other
night together after 40 years
of doing hundreds of millions
of dollars worth of deals
together.
And it started with
him calling and saying,
I don't think you
really meant to do that.
And I was a kid.
I mean, I was
just-- I was pretty
fresh out of business school.
And they used to
crush me in that deal.
He's going to be--
he'll be fired
or something bad
will happen to him.
Who really cares?
I'm talking about a
big-time New York financier.
Who cares about this
kid down in Texas?
But what he did was he
helped me through that.
20 years later, when
the real estate markets
were melting down, he owned
some property in Houston, Texas.
And I said, I'll take those.
I absolutely selected
the properties
that he was in and
said, I'm going
to take those on and
work them out for him.
And they weren't the
most profitable for me,
but I remember 20 years ago.
So I think what
happens is you leave
these little chits around.
And it can be a
conversation with somebody
where you do a kindness,
that it builds trust.
And you remember.
I mean, my guess is
that if I quizzed
the people in this room,
you would remember the three
or four teachers in your
life, the three or four
people in your life
that believed in you
and went the extra mile,
as you say, for you.
So I think it may not be big
or exciting to everybody,
but it's a little conversation.
It's a little event,
doing the right thing.
Most of the time it pays off.
Sometimes it doesn't.
If you expect it
to, then I think
you're going to be disappointed.
But a lot of times,
it does pay off.
And that's the
right thing to do.
And you'll be happier, and you
can pass what I call the mirror
test, you know?
You want to pass the
mirror test every day.
Was that any better?
AUDIENCE: Much better.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: It seems like
as consumers or citizens,
we trust institutions
differently
than we trust the people who
comprise those institutions.
We trust Congress differently
than we trust congresspeople,
or we trust
newspapers differently
than we trust journalists.
How do you account
for this difference,
and what can we do
about it to be--
do about it to be sort of better
at making this distinction?
JOEL PETERSON: You know,
I hadn't thought of that.
That's a really
interesting thing.
I think you're right.
It could be that we
trust the concept.
It's like Plato's
types, you know?
It's kind of the archetype,
the perfect thing,
when we trust the type.
But when we see
the reality of it,
we see the tragic
nature of human nature--
so how do you translate that?
I'll have to give some
more thought to that.
I think it's an
interesting observation.
AUDIENCE: Your next book.
JOEL PETERSON: Yeah,
it's the next book.
David, you work on that one.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: He's smiling.
You can't see his face, but
he's really excited about it.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I guess I might have
sort of a follow-up
question to when you were
talking about apologies
and forgiveness.
With the anecdote that you
just said about doing something
later on or trying to rebuild
trust in different ways,
do you think then that it's
absolutely necessary to receive
an apology to give forgiveness?
Or is that something
that can be freely given?
That you put the impetus on
you to just be forgiving,
and then hope that
something comes down
the road instead of trying?
Or deciding that this
is a time that it's
going to sever this
connection, or just
trying to let it
go, essentially?
Because trying to, I guess,
be the person to do it
and then not think about the
winning or loss of that round,
but just in a
larger sense of, you
don't want to live
harboring this hatred,
even if it's something
that they may never
do another good
thing for you again.
JOEL PETERSON: Yeah.
I think you can let go of it.
And I think that's the ideal.
And I actually come
from a religious faith
where we're
commanded to do that.
You must forgive.
It's your job to forgive others.
I've just found it's
really hard to do
if somebody hasn't recognized
it and won't recognize it.
It's really hard to let go.
So I think it is
possible, and I think
you should strive for that.
I will just tell you
that it's really hard.
But that's OK.
Lots of things are hard in life.
SPEAKER 1: So we have
about a few minutes left.
We do have books
in the back, and I
want to give Joel some
time to actually sign
the books for you guys.
We can maybe take one last
question from the field,
and then wrap up.
OK.
See, now you're getting
all the hands up.
You're really winning.
JOEL PETERSON: When it's the
one last one, then it's--
[LAUGH]
AUDIENCE: Hi Joel.
Thank you for coming.
JOEL PETERSON:
Yeah, my pleasure.
AUDIENCE: So the four of us work
on Google's US Multicultural
Team.
And one of the areas we focus
is on the LGBT community.
And we've been very
impressed with what
JetBlue has been doing.
A lot of the conversations
we have with other brands
are not as on board
as JetBlue is.
So what recommendations
would you or what suggestions
would you give to other
chairmans or CEOs or people
in your position at
different companies
to kind of participate more in
the LGBT community initiatives,
how to establish themselves
more in that field or anything
around the LGBT community?
JOEL PETERSON: Yeah.
So my view is that
it's no longer so
much the issue of diversity.
Diversity's kind of
last century's term.
I think it's about
inclusiveness now.
And I think inclusiveness
is sort of-- you're just not
very smart, I think, as a
leader if you're not inclusive.
And so if you think about all of
the talents that are available,
you don't want to
cut any talent off.
So I find that it crosses racial
lines, ethnic lines, gender
lines, sexual orientation lines,
it crosses all kinds of lines.
You really, as a
business leader,
you're actually
being stupid if you
don't embrace all of these
various approaches and values.
AUDIENCE: I agree
with you on that.
We just have to
get other people--
JOEL PETERSON: Well, I think
it's a question of enlighten--
I think people, the more
enlightened they are,
the more experience they've had,
the more things they've run,
the more people they've met.
You know, that's another
one of these cases where
I think if people
just in the abstract,
they can classify people.
You know, nobody likes
to be classified.
People are individuals.
And I have rarely
found that when
I get to know an individual,
I don't like them.
That's very rare.
So I think it probably
starts out there.
SPEAKER 1: So
thank you for that.
So I guess to leave
us with a few words
as we all read
this book and share
and collaborate and discuss
this book even after today, what
do you want readers
to kind of leave
with after reading this book?
What do you want
them to remember?
And what's next for you?
JOEL PETERSON: You can be
intentional about building
a high-trust set of
relationships in your life.
There are things you can do.
You can take control
of it in your life.
And I was challenged by a
military guy who came to me
and said, you don't build trust.
You earn trust.
And I said, well,
you do earn it sort
of on a one-off conversation
at a time basis.
But fundamentally, you can build
trust within an enterprise,
within a family.
So you actually think about it.
So I'd really like
people to say,
I can take control of this
powerful element in my life
by learning how to manage it.
What's next for me is I've
threatened to do another--
I think I have one
more book in me,
and I've threatened to do that.
I've taught at Stanford now
for a quarter of a century,
and I think I'm going to
die with my boots on there.
I love teaching young people.
I love the potential that
I see in young people.
SPEAKER 1: Well, we've
enjoyed having you today,
and we're happy to
continue to learn from you.
You're welcome here any time.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
JOEL PETERSON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]